trends come and go but what never goes
out of style are dazzling colors
intricate designs and exquisite
craftsmanship
here are the masters breathing new life
into timeless fashion traditions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
specialization
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
in the villages of gweijo china there is
a rich tradition of embroidery but
perhaps none is more intricate than that
of the meowth
[Music]
[Music]
the meow don't have a written language
instead they use their embroidery to
document their history legends and
culture
[Music]
[Music]
meow embroidery uses incredibly
intricate stitching and hand spun
threads to create the designs
some garments can take years to complete
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
valencia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the beauty of kauai just fills my soul
there are places of extreme beauty
and that for me is the nepali coast
where there's a hidden gem
an old village site called nuelolokai
[Music]
it is an absolutely ideal place to
perpetuate hawaiian culture
[Music]
i teach hawaiian studies here in kawaii
and the children call me kumu
i teach hula
which is hawaiian dance
hawaii which is hawaiian language
which is hawaiian bark cloth oh my god
it's so beautiful in hawaii we did not
have loomed material we made our
clothing and our blankets
from the bark of a tree
[Music]
kappa is made first by growing the plant
and then harvesting it scraping off the
outer bark removing the inner bark and
pounding it out
you've got a pound and pound and pound
and pound and then you need many many
strips and you've felt them together and
pound them all out as one
but you've got to have the materials to
teach hawaiian arts and those materials
are very much based on plants
[Applause]
you have to grow the valky in order to
make kappa
that's why we have been returning to nua
lolokai for 27 years
there are no roads in there it's only
accessible by boat or by air
[Music]
you feel the sense of place when you
land
then you walk along the little trail and
when you look out at the ocean and you
see the turtles that are
resting on a beach they have been on
that beach for centuries
we have only been on that beach more
recently
our first trip into nuala lokay was to
return
ancestral remains or kupuna evie and
ever since that trip
we have been going back to take care of
this old village site
and we have also planted balki there to
make kapa
and i'm so trying to figure out how my
kupuna how my ancestors made it as
beautifully as they have
it's a process
we have to relearn these things
so it's a place of old hawaii that
brings much to
our understanding of perhaps how life
used to be
[Music]
come in right here and you're going to
cut it at the bottom i like to teach my
children about kappa because first of
all they have to learn how to take care
of the plants and then they have to
learn how to harvest them and how to
clean them
and how to pound them
[Music]
they know who they are they know where
they live they know why they live here
and what they can do to help
how do hawaiians see the land
that the land is the chief
and that people are its servants
[Music]
you